foreign
[Music]
crew with the most promising Contender
for the Royal seat of the pirate king
it's understood that his crew members
too must pull their weight and who does
it better than roronoa Zorro first made
to Straw Hat Captain Monkey D Luffy
former pirate Hunter and one of the only
two non-captain members of the worst
generation Zorro ever righteous loyal
and monstrously strong shows his metal
time and time again in the diary
situations always managing to come out
on top and that's why today's video is a
tribute to the exceptional first mate of
the straw hats this is Vinnie tube
bringing to you the top 10 Zorro
Showcases of power get ready to be blown
away by this model of true samurai
Spirit starting off at number 10 is Zoro
pulverizing a group of gamblers in wano
[Music]
there is income
[Music]
in typical Zorro fashion the pirate is
once again lost when he befriends Dono
yasu who later turns out to be an
integral character in The Ark throughout
the series Zorro has the mysterious
tendency to meet and connect with
characters of some importance and in 102
in a twist of fate he encounters yasu's
son the man with the most infectious
laugh to repay his benefactor for a meal
Zoro ends up in a gambling Den where he
uncovers a cheat manipulating the dice a
melee ensues and Zorro surrounded by the
sword-wielding hoodlums enraged but calm
the master of the three sword star
knocks them all out in a jiffy using
just one blade without so much of
scratching them
next up is zoro's stupendous knife slash
this one too is in wano
thank you
serving as his introduction in the
ongoing Arc this incident is a perk to
all of us who miss the warrior pirate in
the preceding whole cake Islander
apprehended on false murder charges
Zorro disguised as the Ronin zorojuro is
sentenced to death by seppuku or ritual
suicide stately in a white kimono
thoroughs perfectly at home playing the
role of a samurai in fact the wano arc
is tailor-made for our favorite
swordmaster just as he gets ready to
slit his stomach he exposes the
magistrate as the actual culprit and
with a slash of his helpless short knife
kills him from a considerable distance
part of the monster Trio with Luffy and
Sanji Zorro certainly lives up to his
name in this unbelievable display of
strength and skill but again it's just
like him to catch the attention of the
entire country contrary to the fervent
appeal of his Samurai allies to lay low
it's always a roller coaster ride
whenever Zorro ends up lost
right after slicing up a galleon ship
into the demon pirate Hunter faces off
against hody Jones which is our pick for
the eighth spot
Post Time skip the straw hats land smack
in the middle of a coup d'etat in ryugu
Kingdom Zoro takes on hody Jones the
captain of the new Fishman Pirates as
his opponent a great white shark fish
man Cody is a Powerhouse of raw strength
and unmatched in combat especially
against humans now earlier on in the
series Zorro had quite a tough time
dealing with another fish man arlong but
two years of training under his rival
and Mentor Dracula mihawk finally plays
off Cody the perfect mean machine to
test sorrow skills is left bloodied and
unconscious fighting underwater while
holding his breath and against a fish
man taboo isn't something to be sniffed
at zoro's display against hody shows
that he is well on his way to surpassing
mihog as the world's greatest Swordsman
three
races
[Music]
lucky number seven is none other than
the Pinterest clash in snow clad Ringo
between Zorro and killer
right in the middle of an intense battle
with a demon human hybrid called
yukimaru Zoro is forced into an even
more dangerous contest by garmazo an
elusive manslayer in wano camazo we now
know is killer a member of the kid
pirates who has somehow ended up working
as a hired assassin the fight between
two fellow members of the worst
generation is nothing short of
spectacular a very Japanese Jewel
between a ronin and a manslayer the
speed and destruction are out of this
world to the point of changing the
landscape their bloodlust is palpable
even though killer manages to stab Zoro
with his sight no thanks to gyokimaru's
interference Zoro hacks him down with
his next attack it's plain to see here
that Zorro has outdone most of his
generation in the art of swordplay and
he gets extra points for showing no
hesitation to take on two capable
opponents at once in his desire to
protect the weak and the defenseless
[Music]
foreign
single-handedly besting a hundred bounty
hunters
[Music]
the action takes place early in the
series but remains badass to this day
when the straw had to arrive in the town
of whiskey Peak they're treated to a
raucous party now we all know that this
private crew loves a good Jamboree but
not all that Glitters Is Gold deep in
Slumber from the drinking and
merry-making the unsuspected crew is
surrounded by members of Baroque Works a
clandestine company of bounty hunters
what follows is a Prelude to the
impending Face-Off with crocodile the
straw Hat's first major antagonist Zorro
the only one awakened very much up to
the task takes on the challenge with
relish contrary to how he is now
retreated to a youthful and rash Zoro
who's always up for a fight but as he is
now he's still perfectly capable of
devastating damage Zoro wipes out almost
all the bounty hunters and proves that
against an army of guns his trusted
swords will Triumph any day
thank you
yes Woody
at the Midway market now we head
straight to the alabaster Arc where
Zorro engages in a one-on-one contest
with Daz Bones the Man of Steel
[Music]
A baroque Works officer agent Daz is a
bounty hunter Martian artist and
swordsman more conveniently so because
of his devil fruit power that allows him
to turn his body into steel blades he
goes by the code name Mr one which
indicates that he's second only to his
boss crocodile Daz is a hard Contender
and is even acknowledged by mihawk he's
therefore the perfect opponent for Zoro
to hone his skills although badly cut up
by his difficult foe we must commend the
straw Hat's first mates tenacity and
will to win at all costs cutting steel
is near impossible but Zorro with his
inhuman strength and staggering skills
manages to do just that in a most
stupefying single combat it can be
counted as one of zoro's biggest leaps
in power taking him closer to his goal
of being mihawk successor
yeah
the list gets haunted as Zorro slices
the tricky Pika in half at number four
in the dressross arc Zoro finds himself
pitted against Pika an elite officer of
the Don Quixote family Pika can
assimilate with stone and has just
transformed into a humongous Stone Golem
making him close to Invincible with
innocent lives at stake Zoro literally
flies across the kingdom to get within
Striking Distance of Pika and unleashes
a fierce attack with his hockey imbued
blades he not only manages to cut the
stone monster in half but continues to
slice and dice him until pika's human
form has nowhere to hide this here is
Zorro at his best intelligent intuitive
dependable and supremely cool he's the
kind of champion you want when your life
is in danger thinking back to dress
Rossa zoro's dismantling of Pika is
surely a foreshadowing of what was to
follow starting from that point it's as
if one piece created echiro Oda was
grooming us for wano and zoro's exploits
in the land of the Samurai and boy is it
keeping us glued to our seats
[Music]
[Applause]
one of the most selfless acts in one
piece is at number three it's Zorro's
meaningful encounter with Bartholomew
humor
right after ending the conflict in
Thriller bark the exhausted straw hats
are unlucky enough to run into Cuba
who's come for their Captain with an
unconscious Luffy out for the count of
the rest of the crew know better off
Zorro's the last man standing in a
deeply memorable moment Zorro offers up
his life in exchange for Luffy's even
going down on his knees and giving up on
his dream of becoming the greatest
swordsman the deal with humor means
taking on all the pain in Luffy's
battered body staying true to his
Bushido code Zoro asks Kuma to change
locations so no one can witness his
sacrifice stoic steadfast and courageous
to a fault when Sanji later finds him
alive but standing in a massive radius
of splattered blood Zora replies nothing
happened this moment will live on in the
history of One Piece as the most
honorable Act of any crew
anymore
we're entering the big league now and at
number two we have Zorro stopping big
mom and kaido's combined attack
onigashima
the conclusive battle Atop The Skull
Dome sees Zorro Luffy your kid and
killer go up against the two most feared
and Powerful Pirates of their time the
yonko duo clearly don't think too much
of their challenges and aim to bring
them down in a single shot with zero
hope of dodging the attack the rookies
can only watch in horror as the
atmosphere around them crackles that is
until Zorro without a Thor for himself
steps in front of his allies and blocks
the massive blast deflecting it upwards
and sacrificing himself a firm believer
of the samurai code of facing attacks
head on sorrow never flinches even in
the face of his imminent death having
come a long way since joining Luffy
Zorro has never shown weakness from the
very beginning and he's always had his
captains back as we saw in the episode
with Kuma
[Applause]
if blocking the yonko's attack on his
own wasn't enough Zorro slashes kaido
and gives him a scar to remember for our
top pick today
[Applause]
once again stepping in to protect his
captain The Swordsman makes a valiant
effort to Gold kaido into finishing him
off first having already sustained
serious injuries from kaido and big
mom's attacks earlier he makes one last
stand against the Beast Pirates boss in
a continuation of his black blades
moment against Pika Zoro attacks kaido
with a Heavenly nine sword style display
leaving a deep gash on the yonko's chest
right where kozuki Odin had cut him more
than 20 years ago that he caused his
attack Dead Man's game shows his strong
resolve to lay down his life for his
Captain's cause making the moment even
more significant and openly impressed
kaido hints that Zoro may have just used
conquerors haki Zoro himself is unaware
of this fact as fans who've witnessed
his progress we now know it's only a
matter of time before he assumes the
mantle of the world's greatest Swordsman
foreign
[Music]
Showcases of power please click like And
subscribe if you enjoyed this video and
want more anime content as well as one
piece lists tell me about your favorite
Zoro moments and if they made it to this
countdown in the comments below so long
then until the next video thanks for
watching
foreign